all right we are now live got one person
here already I'll just talk a little bit
as we get started and people start
streaming in so this is the am a session
for October 2019 you can ask me anything
that you like and I will respond in
real-time once the questions start
piling in they there's quite a few of
them usually so you want to get your
questions in fairly early on will go for
about an hour and a half or so you know
we kind of play around with the
deadlines towards the end I will just
start taking whatever questions I can
easily and quickly answer so I'm up here
in the the bedroom right now and as you
can see I'm by my bookshelf so some of
you may see in that bookshelf tour video
all right so we've got some questions
already
Mike ray what are your thoughts on
Bernie Sanders I like Bernie Sanders if
you've ever watched his videos of
interacting with his constituents way
back when he was mayor of Burlington he
has a kind of human touch that many
politicians these days really seemed to
lack as a matter of fact you know
without being a leftist myself actually
being a registered independent there's a
lot of his platform that I think at this
point in time is quite timely you know
so as a candidate I like him quite a bit
you know we'll see what happens there's
some concerns about his health right now
but I think that we'll probably even out
so that's probably enough about that
since we've got other questions popping
up here Muhammad I'm not going to take
the question on Jordan Peterson because
I've talked about him so many times
that's easy enough to find
memento mori what is my opinion on Fuko
do I think
right about the way power works in our
current societies yeah I like Foucault I
think that Foucault like a lot of the
the 20th century sort of cutting-edge
French thinkers you know you don't want
to be a Foucault D in right but it's
good to draw on the places where I think
he gets things right I'm you know I
think he's a he and pure at dole are
both right about you know the notion of
spiritual practices and technologies of
the self of course as a dough you know
makes very clear he's not an innovator
in that respect and what he's calling
philosophy as a way of life has been
practiced by many people long before he
was and there were a lot of other 20th
century French intellectuals who were
talking about that as well like a primer
seller murraysblog Dowler you know
people like that and I think so I think
Foucault was right about that I think
he's actually right in some of his
analyses of power
I like his distinction between
domination exploitation and
subjectification I think that's quite
useful particularly in our digital age
so yeah
Foucault is definitely worth studying
you don't want to be like you know
Foucault fanboy of course any more than
you do on anybody else all right
the proof architect dr. Stadler how
could show up in our have reconciled
with the supply and demand politics of
his lectures without getting angry at
Hegel my thoughts so what are we talking
about with the supply and demand
politics of lectures lectures in the
academy where by the way Hegel at played
a role in getting show up an hour his
job in the first place they were based
on the number of students that you had
studying in your classes so the number
of students attending lectures
Schopenhauer decided to schedule his
lectures at exactly the same time as
Hegel's because he wanted to show up
this fraud Hegel who is you know getting
Kahn trying and all of that sort of sort
of business and of course no but
showed up the Schopenhauer's lectures I
mean a few people did but not as many as
Hegel's I mean he didn't need to
schedule it that way he didn't need to
frame things in that way now to be fair
he was young and I think you know I've
gone through my own hothead a very rigid
period in my life as an intellectual so
maybe show up in how I was going through
something like that
it doesn't appear to have bothered Hegel
much so you know he didn't have the
effect that I think that he wanted to
have Hegel didn't really pay much
attention to it at all he had bigger
fish to fry so to speak so all right
Leonardo Rodriguez my question is about
the difference between your vision and
Hegel and Slava rejects interpretation I
don't know that I can actually even
answer that I mean Jacques can all over
the map right and I can't say that I
have like a comprehensive vision of
precisely what Dziedzic has in mind and
I don't I don't think that I actually
have my own interpretation as such I try
to stay as close to the text as possible
you know I don't I don't aim to be an
original thinker I mean if I if I do say
something that's new or original it's
usually by mistake it might be wrong I
see you know I see Hegel and to be
honest I'm not a a galleon myself I just
see Hegel as somebody who's useful and
he had his his you know finger on a lot
of interesting points so he's worth
studying
but like who Cole you know you you can
take what you need from Hegel the
insights that you you think are
worthwhile and you don't have to buy
into all the rest you know so that's
about as close as an answer I think I
can get to damn the man how do you think
we could get philosophy or just the
humanities in general more respected in
modern society so that's a great
question I think
part of it has to do with humanities
people not being so optimistic about
their capacity to communicate with other
people or about the importance of what
it is that they're they're talking about
you know you've got to make a case for
what it is that you you want to say is
important you get then you have to do it
in the language as best as you can
of non academics so I mean that's what I
strive to do in my videos and I do that
in my academic classes and I do that
with the idea that this is the one
chance that I get I got to put my hair
back a little bit better this is the one
chance that I get to be an ambassador
for my discipline you know and and also
for the people that we're reading so
this isn't probably my one chance to
introduce people to Aristotle or Anselm
or Descartes I don't want to screw it up
I don't want to leave them with a bad
taste in their mouth that's that you
know that is just a reminder that they
wasted their time in that that semester
I want them to to desire to read more
and so I do that in my public lectures I
do that in you know most of the things
that I do and for me that comes fairly
naturally except perhaps with my writing
my writing is a bit convoluted at times
but I mean you hear me speaking right
now all right I can I can talk like an
ordinary person and I think that a lot
of other academics they probably have to
work at it more they have to think they
have to remind themselves hey I may
think that this historical development
is something really cool and important
but it's up to me to to make that case
to other people doesn't mean we have to
dumb it down it doesn't mean that we
have to water it down as a matter of
fact my experience is that audiences if
you can reach them they really do
appreciate rigor and comprehensiveness
but you've got to do that bridge work
first and so you know we actually have
well in our field of philosophy who you
know Thema ties that Aristotle Cicero
right they both said it's important to
know your stuff but it's also important
to be attentive to rhetoric and not
rhetoric and listen to just Volger or
manipulation
you know sophistic rhetoric or anything
like that but you've got to be able to
take into account who your audience is
and think in terms of categories like
ethos you know structure all of that's
quite important so I think when we do
humanities well that's that's part of
what we're doing all right uh multi Pi
how do I feel about Leo Strauss he's
interesting I'm not a Strauss II and
I've read a lot of his work I find some
of his stuff useful I think that you
know his favorite thing the you know
esoteric exoteric distinction is largely
nonsense
that was wishful thinking and his part
became his shtick you know I think it
works with with some people but I don't
I don't buy it the way that he does it
you know as sort of his a thing I don't
like Strauss Ian's they usually tend to
be mean I've met a few really
interesting ones but that's usually
because they're not as Strauss e'en as
they could be movement people joiners
especially a few generations after you
know the key person and the movement is
gone
tend to be kind of you know just
follower types and I think you know it's
now you know I think you could say well
Strauss Ian's are usually a little sort
of in general a higher class than say R
and ian's but they're they're all just
kind of like you know how the the master
or they're just you know using him for
something you know to get some some
traction so all right
asks are there philosophical thoughts on
the use of play yeah I mean Johan
Huizinga the Dutch historian actually
has a whole book called on the play
aspect and culture that that I sometimes
teach when I'm teaching introduction of
human nature courses
he's somebody to look at I mean when you
when you talk about play there's like a
whole literature out there discussing
like play and games and things like that
and then there's also you know the
literature having to do with humor and
jokes and stuff like that so I would I
would start looking around in that that
framework there was a book that I
haven't read for a very very long time
but I remember enjoying it when I was a
teenager called finite and infinite
games that seemed quite interesting and
that might might bear some truth for
that as well alright Spencer Mead what
is the most significant difference
between Aristotle's you name eudaimonia
and epic Epicurus is contentment as the
end of man but I picures doesn't say
contentment I mean the the thumbnail
sketches of Epicurus a ataraxia right
undisturbedly
literally is is what they're after but
at the curious uses the word eudaimonia
to so everybody engage in virtue ethics
talks about eudaimonia the difference is
that that for Epicurus it consists in
two main elements one is enjoying
pleasures active pleasures you know like
say drinking this coffee and also in a
sort of state of absence or from pain or
rest from troubles so the oxy apart
comes in ideally you want to have both
of those right Aristotle says pleasure
is not really the the fundamental goal
it's something that is sort of the icing
on the cake and then Aristotle puts
forth essentially two different
indistinct viewpoints on what the best
life would be the life of happiness one
is its it's a political or social life
that is focused on developing and using
the virtues and so it's committed within
your could be your society could be
within your family could be within your
workspace or something like that and
then there's the contemplative life
which is you know one of teoria you know
literally looking at things and and it's
kind of good to to distinguish this from
a life of say spectator consumerism like
aristotle doesn't think that the life of
watching netflix endlessly and then you
know switching to amazon and switching
to hulu and just watching shows would be
a life of what he's calling theoria
something more activism vol that you're
learning something about reality not to
say that you know watching some things
couldn't be helpful with that and not
just documentaries but even you know
like really good dramas but those are
those are what Aristotle is proposing
and so pleasure comes into that and some
some degree of like absence of pain or
trouble is involved there as well I'll
mention to that a later Aristotelian
Euronymous who we only know by reference
Cicero talks about him in on the ends
and it looks like Plutarch used some of
Corona mice's on anger to write his own
on restraining anger here on Thomas
thought like the Epicureans did that
absence of pain or trouble is a good he
saw that as the the ultimate good that
happiness consisted in that but he's
rather unorthodox as an Aristotelian
along those lines so alright Jamel what
do I think the most impactful work of
philosophy is that's tough I mean if
you're talking about like the one that
has changed the most people's lives or
affected their
distance I don't know you know I mean if
we're thinking about it a global
perspective that makes it even tougher
doesn't it because I mean you could say
Confucius's Analects not written by
Confucius of course but by later
disciples massive cultural influence
right and since the Chinese have in
recent years decided that Confucius is
all right with them and the recoup you
know sort of rehabilitated him for
communist orthodoxy then I suppose maybe
you know they had her one of the other
Confucian classics could could be one of
the most important I mean I mean some
people would probably say like oh you
know Marxist Marx's copy tallbutt copy
tells one of those books that a lot of
people talk about and reference it sort
of like the Bible very few people
actually read much of it you know even
the people who like constantly go on and
on about it I don't know Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics has had a massive
influence it's it's really tough to say
that that's that's a great question and
I don't I don't really have a good
answer for that all right
Jake do you think psychoanalysis still
has any merit or should it be treated as
a pseudoscience of the past well I mean
you should never use the word
pseudoscience without thoroughly knowing
what you're looking into and I think if
you look into psychoanalysis you'll
you'll say that some of it is kind of
sketchy and some of it isn't
and you know it's probably better to
talk about psychoanalysis in the plural
rather than trying to you know
generalize about all of it it's not like
you can read Freud and suddenly know
about contemporary psychoanalytic s--
they've moved on quite a lot from that
right even though they still use some
things from Freud even liqu huh
he had you know talk about in his own
time
how just 20 years after you know some of
these ideas of Freud are like you know
essentially hitting the bricks people
have managed to misunderstand them and
miss apply them in turn psychoanalysis
into something it isn't so I think that
that there are some very useful insights
and practices in psychoanalysis in
certain psychoanalytic schools I mean
you notice when I talk about
psychoanalysis my references are usually
to LeConte and Freud and Kohut and
people like that you know that Winnicott
too you know and so you can say the same
thing with Alistair MacIntyre who when
he had the chance to do a seminar the
faculty Summer Seminar the one that I
was part of he chose to focus on
Aristotle and Thomas Aquinas on rational
choice theory and on frightened Lacan
there's there's good reasons for that
because it's it's not all just you know
nonsense and you know the other thing I
think you want to keep in mind is when
you use the word pseudoscience you need
to have very you don't need to have very
clearly in mind what you what you take
science to be and when we're talking
about the human sciences don't expect
that like just because you've like you
know looked up the scientific method or
something like that that that's exactly
how things how things work in that the
human science or the social sciences
it's not it's not like working with
physics for example so alright um Julian
a really interesting question here how
can you take your ego out of
philosophical discussions and try to
understand and learn rather than win
well right there identifying that as a
problem is part of the solution isn't it
so you can become aware of when you're
falling back into that old pattern
because if this is an issue for you
you've probably done this a lot and and
so it feels kind of
there's a like a natural progression
right at first you're interested in
understanding something and then you
know maybe somebody says something and
it pisses you off and your ego is now
engaged and when we talk about your ego
being engaged you were really talking
about two things one is you know you're
trying to protect your self-image and so
you get defensive about things or go on
the attack but it's also the ego is a
complex of all these patterns and habits
and so these can proceed rather
automatically unless you're you're
paying attention to them to go back to
the psychoanalysis question that's one
of the things you do in therapy right
and it's not like the psychoanalyst have
the corner on that previous forms of
what we would you know call spiritual
direction did that that's something that
people were attentive to in philosophy
as a way of life in terms of virtue
ethics the cognitive revolution does
that as well but that that's something
really essential you got to like
actually pay attention to what you're
typically doing so you they habits don't
control you and you start to get some
some capacity to intervene in the habits
and then it's it's a long laborious
process of like reminding yourself that
you don't want to be a prick you know
and that letting your ego and desire to
win you're in and this is a lot you know
the Greeks had a word for this philony
Kia desire for victory right this is a
basic human Drive that leads us astray
Aristotle even when he's talking about
weakness or failure of will Achrafieh in
Greek he singles out philony kia as one
of the types of aircraft or one of the
motivators for certain types of across
so this is a very common issue I think
one of the things you can do is you can
remind yourself of some of the bad
consequences that come about you know
this this sort of wish to contend screws
up friendships it makes people not want
to work with you
it makes them distrustful of your
motives so you know it's ultimately not
good for you on the way so that I'd say
that's one thing you can do that can
help out um let's see here just skipped
very quickly tubes jumped over a bunch
of stuff Wow a lot of questions here
okay so here we're back proof architect
how do you think the discussion of
censorship policy has to act in the and
look to the Republic differs from how we
talk about censorship today
well censorship is I mean again let's
think in the plural right is there one
single thing that's that's how we talk
about censorship today I don't think so
and you know Plato is talking about one
kind of idea about censorship that we we
censor in a paternalistic way to you
know try to keep people from believing a
bunch of lies and those lies could be
things like you know the gods like to
fight with each other you know Socrates
says Socrates does indeed have a
different conception of the gods than
most people did back done all right
mister dad Dharam paji how difficult do
you think it is to get funding for a PhD
in the US for philosophy and
anthropology I wouldn't know about
anthropology I'm not an anthropologist
at all I can tell you that it's harder
to get funding for the PhD but before
you get a PhD you need an MA right
so don't plan on jumping straight from
the under from the undergrad bachelors
straight into a ph.d program because
unless you you know your GRE scores are
off the charts or you know you've got
some
I'll program the Irian that's usually
not the way it works
funding is up to the schools you know
when I was in school it was pretty
common that if you had funding it
covered all of your tuition and gave you
a stipend the Marquette graduate
students that I work with you know they
are only getting half or a third of
their tuition actually paid for by the
school they got to come up with the rest
with loans or you know other fellowships
or things like that it's much tougher
today but there isn't any like one
single hard and fast answer because as
I've pointed out many times we don't
have an educational system we have a
patchwork of many many different
institutions and systems all working
together so what you would want to do is
actually start talking to people in
programs programs at places that you
might want to go and say how does
funding work here and and see what what
they have to say you want to be a little
bit not so high up perspective you want
to like get a bit more as we say
granular with it right um no crack what
do you personally get out of Maurice
blown Del's thinking I love people who
can you know try to take in the
complexity of life and existence and
Blondell was even better than Agel at
that because writing is not you know for
everybody I mean if you like Cicero
you'll probably like blown down because
you got these giant Ciceronian paragraph
long sentences many of people in his own
time didn't like that but I really like
his sort of scope of thoughts and his
relentlessness and you know there's a
lot of admirable things about him so
yeah let's see Bob bobbin or Levesque
what are showing in Fichte all about are
they proto Hegelians
information is scarce unless you want to
read them yourself yeah read them
yourself I mean why wouldn't you just
read them I mean there and information
is not scarce about them I mean there's
encyclopedia entries devoted
to them you just got to do a bit of
searching right there's lots and lots of
articles out there about them if you go
on academia.edu you'll find lots of
people writing about them I mean to
answer your actual question are they
proto Hegelians I mean victim more than
than shelling I'd say shelling is kind
of doing his own thing he and Hagel work
together very closely by the way in
their their early years I mean
Hagel is using some stuff from Fichte
but Fichte is also a figure in his own
right so you know I start reading some
of their stuff and see what you make of
it sub morally to start reading a book
about Gerrard you have any opinion Adam
if you talking about Rene Girard yeah I
think that the idea of mimetic desire is
a brilliant insight and I don't know
that I buy into like the whole logic of
sacrifice stuff but he's an interesting
thinker definitely deserves more
attention than he then he gets Mary Ruth
says love your t-shirt yeah as I get
this for joining the KISS Army and and
you know I've been listening to kiss
since I was about six seven you know one
of the kids on my block had kiss alive
and yeah we used to like you know be
there drawing with crayons we'd always
like draw you know kiss stuff I was
fascinated with Ace Frehley the spaceman
so who I got to see him concert just a
couple a year ago or two years ago
quite good martin costa thoughts on
thomas pynchon's fiction i don't read it
here's another one
you know on aerelon Aaron's son have you
read David Bentley's heart new book that
all shall be saved heaven Helen
universal salvation nope
you know I'm so busy I don't I don't get
time to read an awful lot of stuff
outside of the things I'm working on or
teaching
so yeah Mohammed what philosophy do you
recommend individuals with stem
backgrounds same as every other you know
I always say start with Plato the fact
that you have a stem background doesn't
make you special
you have the same human capacities as
anyone else unless you choose to like
identify yourself and sort of a blind
'red way as a stem individual you know
is there anything in particular for some
people I mean you decide this it's not
like it's not like there's such a thing
as stem people you know some sort of
character trait you interact with people
who are in you know engineering or you
know the science is there's a very mixed
bag aren't they so you know you're gonna
read the same philosophy stuff as
anybody else if you want to make
progress in philosophy you off marcello
fernandez what's the relation between
the prime mover and nature in Aristotle
I kinda understood the things grow move
because of want to the prime mover but I
must be I might be very mistaken could
you clarify this there's not much to
clarify Aristotle doesn't tell us an
awful lot about that so it's not really
worth spending a lot of time on because
it's it's what we call underdetermined
and the things that you know Aristotle
had here something else a the things
that Aristotle has to say where it's
kind of just sort of like thrown out
there and there isn't that much to it
it's probably not Aristotle you want to
read its commentators on Aristotle who
then are picking up these issues and
working them out further rather than
just like trying to cobble together
something interesting out of all these
little passages here and there why not
look at somebody who has more to say
about like Alexander of Aphrodisias or
you know jump ahead to the medieval
Aristotelian 's or I'm sure there's
probably plenty of stuff on that in the
Islamic Aristotelian zall though I don't
read Arabic so I don't have anything to
say about that all right
Leo Nora do I think that Heidegger and
Hegel are is helpful useful to the
life is Stoics are they just useful for
academic purposes well that's a bit of a
false dilemma there isn't it either the
other things are like as useful as the
Stoics for ordinary life or they're
merely academic I mean it depends on
what kind of life you have doesn't it
Heidegger is like full of brilliant
insights into how we perceive things in
our environments why would you not want
access to that I mean that's already
there and being in time it's not like
you know there's high daguerreian
exercises the way there are with the
Stoics but sometimes you can kind of
figure it out as you go along but but if
you if you push it to the side is like
merely academic that's probably gonna
that's gonna sort of taint what you're
doing with it Hegel is tougher to use I
would say than hiding her in that
respect but there's plenty of stuff that
you could draw out of the phenomenology
looking at particular dynamics you know
especially this stuff you know everybody
wants to go to the master-slave
dialectic just you know forget about
that for a while focus on what's going
on in the middle part of the work the
real core the reason and the spirit
sections and there's like all these
really cool dynamics where you you know
you're reading it you're like holy crap
that's like what happened last week or
holy crap that's like what's going on
the culture wars right now and and so
that can be very helpful you know and
and you don't have to like pick and
choose between them too you can you know
what I work with clients you know for
philosophical counseling I'm often
bringing up the Stoics but I'm also
bringing up the Aristotelian xand
platanus and existentialist and that you
know dialectical philosophy and
sometimes you know psychoanalyze
thinkers where they're appropriate just
bring all these these elements together
so yeah all right let's see here
Syd
relax I want Schopenhauer's philosophy
to be my area of research I want to ask
you something else how may one look at
addiction say through the lens of
idealism well whose idealist you mean
Schopenhauer's do you mean Hegel's
they're both idealists they'd have
different answers I mean the first thing
to do is start digging around in their
text and see if they discuss addiction
in interesting ways
but you know I don't know that I have
much more to say beyond that all right
am all about toulon thoughts on Orthodox
Christianity in the essence energy
distinction I don't have any thoughts on
that have you read a dialogue between an
Orthodox and a bar Allah might I don't
think so Dylan do I believe there is
intelligent life elsewhere in the
universe I don't really have a belief
about that because I I mean I don't know
so obviously if somebody shows up and
you know walks off their ship or
something like yeah then I'll believe it
but I don't this I don't I don't say
well there can't be any life because we
haven't heard anything from it there are
a lot of different possibilities
space is vast so I just don't know you
know
phantom upload what are your thoughts on
here at cleitus Heraclitus is
interesting but there's not much to be
done with him because we've just got
fragments we don't have we don't have
his book on nature and so he's what you
call a wax nose anybody can make of him
what they want you know it appears that
there were like Kerik Lydians back in
the day because Plato talks about that a
little bit and Lucian of Simon sorta
references them as a sect somebody else
does is well I think I think maybe
Cicero or Plutarch does but we really
don't know much about him so I you know
I think it's important to focus on what
we've got them
old stuff rather than trying to piece
together you know some sort of Herrick
Lydian doctrine jeff sullivan any
thoughts on Spinoza it seems like you're
a big fan of live minutes and Descartes
thanks for your work yeah good luck with
the crazy work full this month yeah this
or this love this month is is indeed
crazy as you move up to stoic on
Milwaukee Espinoza is interesting I see
him as sort of a dead end i I don't I
don't have the enthusiasm for him that
many other people seem to have but I
think that a lot of that enthusiasm is
reading other things into him you know
reading their own their own stuff into
them I mean with the for example with
the lose when you go to you know Deleuze
in history of philosophy you're getting
like maybe one-third actually history of
philosophy and two-thirds to lose and
it's fun because to lose is pretty cool
you know and interesting but let's not
pretend that it's actual like history of
philosophy focusing very closely on the
figure and I just you know I I don't I
don't get that much out of Spinoza
I mean I've studied him I've I've taught
him occasionally but he's just you know
it's not that interesting to me not like
Descartes is some proof architect what
do you consider the difference between
existentialism and absurdism I don't
think there is a difference because I
don't think either one of them is a
sharply defined concept I think that
anybody can call themself an absurdist
and I think that historically
existentialism is a what we call a
family resemblance concept and I think
that cow Moos philosophy of the absurd
which is not absurdism is a form of
existentialism as you know I don't
really care about his denial of that
because Heidegger also says he's not an
existentialist and so does Marcel
they're all existentialist s-- they're
just existentialist in different ways
we shouldn't get too caught up on I'm
worrying about these division lines
especially when we're dealing with with
movements that are quite fluid like that
um Dominic do you have any tips for slow
readers it's actually a good thing to be
a slow reader because there are so many
people out there today who you know like
brag about how many books they're
reading you know and how fast they got
through you know this and that and you
know or even like these people who like
they watch they watch videos and they're
like I watched that one in 3/4 speed I'm
like that sounds really dumb you know I
mean that's like a great recipe for
making sure you have a sort of trivial
superficial understanding of things and
you you know reading slowly is actually
a good thing to do it's it requires you
to you know in the Middle Ages they use
the metaphor of rumination right you
ruminate upon what you're reading you
chew by by thinking it over by
reflecting it's not a goal to like get
through it right away so so it may not
be that bad of a thing that you you read
slowly maybe you're paying closer
attention you know all right
Mia bear what should I read if I want to
understand spirits the way that Rilke
understood them probably a lot of Rilke
I mean what have you read probably some
poems and letters to a young poet he
writes a lot there's there's even get
collected letters of Relkin which he
explains lot of his ideas to other
people in the letters so that hey I
would do that
a burner I was wondering if you could
explain with the pre-socratics Plato and
Aristotle thought physical manner was
they think it wasn't just material but
something more
I would go to metaphysics book one for
some of that because Aristotle actually
talks about his predecessors and what he
takes them to have thought it was in the
case of many of the pre-socratics we
don't have much of their writings so you
know and the word for matters who lay in
greek right which originally means wood
so clearly it's a it's an idea that gets
generalized different in aristotle than
it is in plato it's different in plato
it appears than it wasn't some of his
predecessors although we don't know that
much about them
so I would I would take a look at what
Aristotle has to say in metaphysics book
one and then go back and you know read
some of them
all right the proof architect what do I
think mathematical finance ist's are
constructivists I don't know enough
about them it's been so long since I've
been doing philosophy of mathematics
that I don't have anything valuable to
say Alejandra Ramos I've been recently
getting into the lose and want to read
anti Oedipus should I dive tried drive
right into it well that's an interesting
question that you ask because anti
Oedipus is not to lose anti Oedipus is
Deleuze and guitar e and my feeling
people can you know Sam totally wrong
about this is that the lose is more
interesting when he's writing on his own
than when he's writing with guitar I
don't I don't think that guitar E was
really a good influence on on de luces
thought in some respects but that could
be just personal you know like I really
enjoy the logic of sense and you know
maybe that's a good place to start or
you know the histories of the history of
philosophy stuff that he's got i like
those books even though they're like i
said more to lose than you know live
netzer or Spinoza or niche or whatever
I'm
that big on auntie Oedipus I mean it
can't hurt to read it that was my
introduction to Deleuze as a matter of
fact I'm I'm gonna take a little pause
I'll tell you a funny story
so in undergraduate I went to this place
called Lakeland College which is now
Lakeland University and like a lot of
places they got themselves an education
program I think they have a nursing
program now maybe offer an MBA or
something like that
and they've gotten rid of their
philosophy program which makes sense
because you know there was never that
many majors in it and quite frankly the
people that were teaching there in
philosophy they were not particularly
good at you know the field nor did they
stay on top of things so they what they
told us basically was in the
contemporary philosophy class you know
sort of depicted this there's analytic
philosophy which was you know getting
its start with like Russell and more and
Vidkun Stein and going you know up to
people like wine and and all that there
was actually had quite a few kind of
cool analytic philosophy stuff that was
fairly cutting edge in the library but
none of the teachers were reading it
then they thought you know there's
American philosophy like pragmatism but
that's not really philosophy then
there's process philosophy that's real
metaphysics and then there's
existentialism you know and that was the
representative of continental philosophy
I mean if you wanted to you could read
some Hegel but nobody really cared about
him and so I'm taking this modern
philosophy class with four other
students one of them was a Japanese guy
whose family had made a killing in the
real estate market in Tokyo and so he
was just over at Lakeland studying and
he could buy all sorts of books his name
is Yoshi Hiro and about halfway through
the semester he he said to me because he
didn't speak English very well I was
like what if I write a paper would you
present the paper form it could we had
to write papers and present them
class and I was like yeah that's not a
problem you know be happy to take a look
at what you're writing so he's like well
you're gonna need these books in order
to understand what I'm what I'm talking
about
and he gave me an T Oedipus and some
Foucault stuff Bakhtin he gave me like
two books by him one was a the
Dostoevsky poetics book and I forget I
think the other one had maybe the
Rabelais book there was a bunch of other
stuff in there too it was stuff that I
hadn't been exposed to right and so I
started reading through this stuff and
then I read his paper his paper came to
be like 50 pages long and it was
basically making the argument that
modern philosophy had gone from being
dialogic to monologic probably you know
true in some respects and you know I
started reading this stuff and I was
getting into this again it was really
cool you know but I didn't I couldn't
say that I fully understood that
probably didn't even have understood
well good portion of what I was reading
but then I had those books right and now
I you know I carry them with me and go
from place to place and you know they
became part of my my repertoire but I
didn't really start reading to lose
other than anti Oedipus in a serious way
until graduate school and that was those
you know kind of nice so yeah I mean
yeah you can dive right into anti
Oedipus realize that it's a little bit
dated in some respects there he's really
complaining about the French
psychotherapeutic and and dominated by
psychoanalytic establishment that's
really what the book is is focusing on
when it comes to that sort of stuff you
know a lot of the targets for the book
are kind of long long dead but you can
still get something out of it so yeah
alright renew do I think there's a
chance that the gods directed button on
the nature of the gods could be actually
the ancient aliens from long ago I mean
anything is possible but that's not one
that I'm
actually gonna put any interpretive way
down because I don't buy into that that
sort of mythology and it is just a
mythology of ancient aliens you know
being gods that sort of business all
right
[Music]
Andrew why do people turn to dangerous
pleasures rather than using reason well
I mean sometimes they do use reason
figuring out how to get more of those
dangerous pleasures don't they you know
I mean you're kind of answering the
question they they don't use reason the
way that they ought to in a more
substantive way and so they they jump
into dangerous pleasures and there's all
sorts of reasons I mean oftentimes
people want pleasures in order to
compensate for how much their life sucks
they they want to use it too as people
say feel alive or sometimes to numb
themselves or sometimes as a
compensation you know I I my life sucks
here so I should have this pleasure here
sometimes it becomes habitual a lot of
times it's because they're in an
environment where people are are not
only pursuing and enjoying but also
valuing pleasures more than than other
things you know I mean that's one of the
things if you grow up poor it's not like
poor people are you know not as smart in
managing money as other people just sort
of naturally and that's why they're poor
that's that's a [ __ ] you know
backwards explanation part of what
happens when you're poor is you're stuck
in situations where you have to make
shitty choices over and over and over
again and those often wind up is you
know resulting in habits being form like
you know thinking about just the the
present moment because the lights might
be out next week you know so I mean
that's the this is sort of like one of
the big questions that you see virtue
ethics theories dealing with mr. despair
have you ever been pissed off at a
philosophical concept that's that's not
a good one I don't know
where you're like holy [ __ ] that's so
stupid how could anyone possibly believe
it
maybe I mean I don't I don't know
anything that pops into my head I do get
ticked off at people who believe really
stupid ideas particularly when they've
had the opportunity to to learn you know
how stupid those ideas are and to
acquire better ideas but I don't think I
get angry at the ideas themselves I
suppose I suppose there's probably a lot
of people out there who do though you
know I mean like think about when
somebody is like ah that's fascist man
you know or oh that's you know it's kind
of funny because fascism yeah we
probably should have we shouldn't
associate that with bad stuff that
socialist man that socialism could be
good at bad depends on what kind of
socialism it is but if you have an
automatic knee-jerk reaction like many
Americans to do the very word socialism
that's something to look into it thank
all right proof architect yes again you
know certain philosophy departments have
reservations of teaching Heidegger
because it does not see affiliation how
do you try to advocate his philosophy as
valuable
yeah there's some there's also a lot of
them that don't teach Heidegger because
he's continental you know a lot of
analytic dominated departments that
don't teach Hegel either or or Nietzsche
or Thomas Aquinas or don't even
effectively teach Descartes they
probably teach Descartes but then they
stop after the second meditation yeah or
things like that but yeah there's some
who don't you know there's a there's
there's a serious discussion out there
about how much of his work is tainted by
Nazism you know you've got everything
from like all of it to only the stuff
that explicitly mentions National
Socialism does somewhere in the middle
being in time arguably not Nazi you know
black no books obviously Nazi so it
really depends how do you advocate as
philosophy as valuable you
show it you show that there's things in
it that can be used all right oh nice
Alejandro been recommending your channel
to everyone I can think find it helpful
keep doing what you're doing love from
Colombia it's nice that it's getting out
there I mean I kind of wish that YouTube
did a better job in like providing
closed caption translations but even the
English closed caption stuff isn't
really that great so but it's cool that
people are watching it so Zorba what is
my view on big Dan and how it's used to
understand human behavior that's a great
question so I think a lot of people and
I've seen this I mean this is before the
era of big data I would see this a lot
when I go to political science
conventions to talk with the poly SCI
theory people but I'd stray into the the
quantitative analysis things and I'd be
like holy crap is this terrible science
you know these categories that they've
got set up from like you know the
conservative to liberal perspective
they've got these numbers and if you you
know trigger this thing the right way
you're in this hopper and that hopper
and I'd be like there are so many
methodological assumptions being made
here that I don't think they're aware of
and all they want to do is quibble but
which statistical model did you use
might be like you guys have fundamental
ground problems here I think that's the
case of big Danna I think that you know
it's it's it's really a matter of like
generating lots of information watching
which is crap information and it'll get
used for stuff and then we're all kind
of stuck with the results so there's
this really funny sci-fi story and I
don't remember who wrote it but earth is
at war with another planet and they're
they're the two planets are shooting
missiles at each other that that like
blow off each other stuff and earth wins
the war
and it's due to this gigantic computer
that
is processing all the data and then
giving you know the orders to the
military what to do and the the Chiefs
of all the divisions get together after
that and they're like one of them's like
I got a confession to make
you know when we were like feeding
information to the computer we couldn't
actually trust the information that was
coming to us from like the you know the
the spies and reporters and all that so
we kind of fudge the data that we put in
there and that's a problem because right
garbage in garbage out with the
computers and then the computer you know
the the military people were like well I
mean it sounds bad but actually it's not
that bad because the computer like gave
us orders and then on some of them we
followed them but others you know we
were like this is actually this is not a
good order so we're gonna like we're
gonna fake it and say that the computer
said this to do this you know particular
attack or something like that we're
gonna do what we think is best and then
the technicians who actually handled the
computer itself we're like well we got a
confession to make too the computer was
never really operating the way it was
supposed to so we actually processed a
lot the data ourselves and then you know
spit out the answers that we thought
should be the right ones and you know
then they all had a good chuckle because
as it turned out you didn't really need
the computer in the first place it was
just sort of a prop a lot of big data is
like that you know people use it to to
justify what they what they want to do
Mason any
tips on any tips to help learn Latin
depends on how you learn you know I
think that there's a lot of good like
programs out there I mean I I learned my
Latin a long time ago so I don't and I
don't teach Latin so I don't I don't
really focus on that but some of the
people that I correspond with tell me
that there's like cool computer programs
that help you out
and there's always Wheelock you know all
right let me skip down a bit no crack no
smack what philosophers would you
recommend that talked about spike
Aristotle's one of the first people that
I know that talks about something like
that at a few places in his work he he
talks about what we translate us by
Epidaurus most as a cause of anger and
rhetoric booktube he also discusses
malice epic hater yeah literally setting
your hands
no not epic adrià man i can't remember
the name but it literally means like
setting your hand to two wickedness
right spiders we need you like screw is
somebody and you're not even getting
anything out of it's different than
hubris where you're like I'm superior to
you because I pissed in your your boots
or something like that spike you're not
even gonna get anything out of it you
still piss in the person's boots or
whatever you're gonna do right so
Aristotle talks about it then who else
talks about it maliciousness there's a
lot of Christian thinkers who mention it
here and there usually it's gonna be
rooted in something right
the person says they're not getting
anything out of it that if we analyze
that maybe they view it as a chance to
like pay somebody back or something like
that all right miss missed in what kind
of world do you think will be living in
2050
so how old why it's almost 2020 I'm
gonna be 50 in 2020
I'd be 70 in 2050 I don't know I mean it
looks like climate change is happening
so it might be a world where there's a
lot less land space things might be good
bit hotter overall and a lot of global
instability because of it that's what
the US military thinks by the way and
the RAND Corporation and people who make
bets on these sorts of things I don't
know I hope we haven't screwed it up too
badly it probably won't be a you know
we're probably still gonna have like a
lot of the same basic technology as we
do today because if you look back at the
projections from the past about like how
everything's gonna be totally different
by 2020 that ain't the case what's up
mister to spare any book you would
recommend to someone struggling with
regrets it really depends on what you
regret so I don't think I have much more
to say about that rock cash if you want
to choose between nihilism and
existentialism which one do you prefer
that's not even a question for me
existentialism I draw on existentialism
pretty heavily fgh I don't I don't
really pay attention to antinatalism so
that's not gonna be helpful Coen Davis
do you know any Asian or African
philosophy yeah I mean I've taught
classes on African or Africana
philosophy when I was at Fayetteville
State University and I've taught classes
on Asian philosophy and I was working
for Ball State University so I've read
around I'm not an expert in the field so
I can't you know I don't know I can't
read like classic Chinese or Sanskrit so
I'm a little bit leery about you know
pontificating about what's going on in
texts myself but yeah mister
spare my red holdback heaven red hold
back Mark Barrow
what if our investments and belief or
theory draw us into petty bias
what if yeah then you you if you figure
that out try to pull yourself out of it
if not you know maybe hopefully you if
some other people can help you out right
all right uh some thanks from so bought
Bock VP Master 99 so when I drop by say
thanks for saving my butt and philosophy
last year you let me understand this
today courts Day cards a discourse that
method as well as con that's very good
the proof architect have you followed
the recent Hong Kong protest protesters
opinion is that nonviolent pacifist
demonstration is not feasible after the
2012 umbrella riots how to analyze with
philosophy it's a good question a lot of
different ways you could you could look
at it you know in sort of a cost-benefit
utilitarian way you know what what is
likely to produce the best outcomes
overall you have to figure out what the
right outcomes are you might think of it
in terms of Rights
you know and upholding people's rights
to say you know the basically the things
that the the British had in the legal
system before the Chinese government you
know took over Hong Kong and you can
also look at it in terms of you know the
mores of the people it's gonna be
difficult for mainland China to really
assimilate Hong Kong given how
fundamentally different things are there
so I mean there's a lot of things you
could you could do learn something I've
given a lot of thought to although it's
you know still developing and it's
mostly because I'm just so busy you know
Taunton I'm Sebastian from Chile I've
been watching your videos for some time
I always wonder if you're a Christian
Catholic I mean if you're a believer can
faith affect philosophy yeah I mean I'm
got a record and Catholic I'm not a
particularly devout one
that written a lot within the Catholic
intellectual tradition you know did my
dissertation on race blown now I don't
you know I don't consider myself under
some obligation to evangelize and I'm
not particularly happy with what I see
going on in the the church you know sort
of at the day-to-day level where where
we have a lot of problems and you know
it's interesting when I taught in
Indiana State Prison I was told I was
gonna be teaching religious study in
philosophy classes I was told keep
whatever religious affiliation you have
to yourself and it was a good thing I
did because there was a lot of you know
sort of knee-jerk anti-catholic
prejudice from people would go on to
sort of low church protestant churches
and really didn't know much and we're
reading people like Helen white all that
but it was also good that I did that
because that way I didn't have any of
the other Catholics thinking they could
like get over on me or you know know
where I was coming from because they'd
read a bit of Thomas Aquinas or
something like that
you know I don't think you know here's
the thing that I always say so when
somebody says oh I'm a Christian right I
always say that's cool how you doing
with the Sermon on the Mount because
otherwise I don't hear any your [ __ ]
I don't want to hear about Leviticus and
you know homosexuality I don't want to
hear about your views on Israel I don't
want to hear your views on you know
male-female relationships and gender
roles if you can't actually like put
into effect the Sermon on the Mount
which is a central you know sort of
Christian teaching throughout their the
history of the church all the rest is
kind of just you know posturing and that
usually shuts a lot of people up you
know I don't think it's really that
important whether somebody is a
Christian or a Catholic I think I think
we look at their philosophical work on
its own grounds you know all right
Zachary thank you for sharing so much
full
soon at the Internet I often suggest
your videos to friends when they are
interested that's very good glad they're
there helpful for you Jake to what
extent do you think it's possible to
separate the philosopher as a person
from their work depends on the work I
mean G Moore is a great example he
apparently you went on the record as
saying that he didn't read he didn't
read much philosophy he actually much
preferred reading novels to reading
other people's philosophy it was kind of
a you know a job that he did and he was
pretty good at it but he could have done
other things instead okay that's quite
different than say Nietzsche hey so it
depends on the philosophy or the
philosophy you you know I don't think
you can completely generalize about that
and this is a question I suppose that
that may be philosophers themselves
think about you know to what extent are
they a person more than than just their
profession I mean you get into
philosophy and do it if you're if you're
actually good at it and and you know you
want to like do like live up to the sort
of like the spirit of philosophy
whatever that is because you find
something there that is really valuable
and you know you think needs to be
engaged with otherwise you're just a
placeholder other there's lots of
placeholders an academic philosophy you
know just kind of taking up space they
should get the [ __ ] out of the way so
other people could do better work than
them but there are also a lot of people
who are really really committed and you
know they're doing what they're doing
because they they see something really
valuable there all right made of clay
what determines the value of a human
life is there something undeniable that
gives a human it's worth my even asking
the right question when it comes to
value on human I mean there's I think
you can say
that you if you're asking the thing like
where's the cutoff right when is it okay
to kill this person when is it not
I think that's a different question than
like what do we fundamentally share in
common that gives most value
I would say personhood not an answer
that was recognized as such in a lot of
ancient philosophy but you can read it
back in there and you know it's it's
when we think of like going beyond the
mere animal and what what you know what
if the entire scope of being a rational
animal brings to it I think that's
that's part of it not that you know
because we're discovering by animal
observing animal behavior not that
animal behavior isn't very very complex
and contains many of the things that we
think are valuable like the capacity to
empathize or you know we mentioned play
earlier on being able to play with
others is something important to all
right
Callum cap were do I do work on JL
Austin perception theory I think you
know that's a very easy question to
answer just by you know looking at my
stuff the answer is no my great what are
your thoughts on dubious folks using
Christianity to justify hatred of LGBTQ
is there a Christian case for acceptance
of gays or said dubious folks correct as
someone cherry-picking well like I like
I mentioned I think a lot of Christians
are not really Christians I think that
I'll go on record as saying this I think
that the conservative Catholics and
evangelicals in this country who have
hitched their wagon to Trump's star
ceased being even what what level of
Christian they had at that time because
they're there they're there policies are
so unrecognizable from a Christian
perspective that's rooted in you know
the actual example and teachings of of
Christ or the historical teachings of
the church I mean if you want to know
what the church has to say about
economics you know there was labora
Mexicans right and before that there was
Ray Romano varam and if you read that
sort of stuff you can't be a liberty
you can't be you know a a business gets
to do whatever the hell they want kind
of person now going back to the LGBTQ
question right we know a good bit more
about about human drives and behavior
the whole question of like is it a
choice or is it determined it's a
[ __ ] question we need to look at
like individual people and say there's
probably like this much in this case and
this much in this case when people are
are you know decrying you know
homosexuality as a sin or anything else
you know being queer but they're
engaging in adulterous behavior
themselves adulterous behavior is
defined by say again the Sermon on the
Mount right then they're full of crap
and they don't deserve to be taken
seriously and they should just be called
antichrists because that's really what
they are they're against the the message
of the founder and whatever they're
doing is probably you know there's some
good in what they do and the rest of it
is just spreading crap I'm glad today
that things are not you know at least in
some areas what they were like when I
was a kid I mean I'm not I'm not gay
right I'm a daught of sexual but I
remember seeing kids mercilessly bullied
sometimes at the point of being terribly
beaten you know for even some of them
weren't even weren't even gay they you
know did the wrong thing everyone was a
sort of an edge all the time
no you can't attribute all of that so
it's a conservative Christianity there
was plenty of other cultural things as
well going on but that that played a
role in it and people who like our
nostalgic for that time I think they're
idiots now that said on the other side
so now now that I've pissed off people
on the conservative side let me piss off
people on the left there's an awful lot
of posturing and like you know III after
like B every space has to be my space
and it's one thing to say I should have
a safe space it's
other thing to say I should be able to
get in everybody's face all the time
about my sexuality that's [ __ ] - you
know we all have to live together and
you know there's there's a lot of people
doing a lot of posturing around but
right now I think for me I'm more
repulsed by the right that I am by the
left and that's different because if
you'd asked me 10 years ago it would
have been the opposite and maybe 10
years from now it will be the opposite
for me but right now that's that's where
I sit on there all right um so here's a
really interesting question from Khalil
thank you for all your public service is
a philosophy educator and a more
personal known how are you feeling about
where you are in life at this moment in
your life good question
so I'm gonna turn 50 next August and
instead of like waiting for a you know
the to reach 50 before I start making
some resolutions and thinking about
stuff I decided it would make more sense
for me to decide what I want to be the
case by the time that I'm 50 so am I
happy with where things currently are no
I would like to more or less have sorted
out what I'm going to be doing
professionally you know I do a lot of
different things teaching you know way
too many classes this semester I don't
want to do that anymore instead I want
to be spending more time doing client
based work I'm all I'm doing a lot of
that too but I want to do more of that I
want to do a lot more writing I want to
continue video production I want to do a
lot more public speaking and I want to
build out my own online classes which
I've done a little bit but I haven't
haven't done to the degree I'd like I
want to teach basically just for
institutions at where I feel valued
which is not always the case and so
that's the professional side of things
and I you know I've made sort of
commitments that I haven't always been
able to follow through on especially in
terms of book projects I'd like to get
those books written I'd like to have you
know a sort of better connection with my
kids being being more involved in their
life and that's tough to do because they
live at a distance you know I'm divorced
and they're two states away and and you
know they're quite you know occupied
with their own things going on but I you
know I want to be fully there when
they're here and you know I try calling
just about every night don't always
reach them I can't do it when I'm
teaching or other things like that to
become more regular but that's not
entirely up to me and I'd like to spend
more time with my biological father and
my half-brother and sister you know
that's that's important to me as well
obviously I want to lose some weight
exercise more regularly get back into
not the shape I was in in my 20s but
closer to that than where I've been you
know work on my personality in certain
respects there's a lot of things and I
you know I've got a lot of matters that
I need time in order to really think
through you know when I was 11 I my dad
died and I was told as I was turning 12
that I was now the man of the house
didn't even cry at his funeral you know
took me years to do that later and
there's a lot of things unresolved about
about what it was like to grow up when I
did so I want to work through those
those things as well so that's my
feeling about where I am at this moment
in my life I'd also like to you know
like to be a better teacher in some
respects so all right dangerous kitty
can you talk about some of your favorite
philosophical films or movies
get from that perfect a little bit
follow up how about the ethical
implications movies like it's a
wonderful life or Groundhog Day or dark
night well those are kind of you know
obvious ones right Groundhog Day is
about what what would your life be like
if you have to repeat it over and over
again
I was redone recently with that one with
uh what is her name
Natasha something Russian doll it was
pretty good we're just talking about
this actually at the book signing for
Veronica Roth's new new short stories
somebody came up to me afterwards and
they were talking about philip k dick
and they said with what's your favorite
movie
focused on philip k they're grounded in
philip k dick stories and i thought well
I really do like Blade Runner but it's
not very faithful to the story and and
my favorite dick novel has shifted from
being man in the high castle which I
felt to be the best a couple years ago
to Scanner Darkly and that was a really
good movie raised a lot of key issues in
a way faithful to to the author I'd say
so there's you know there's quite a bit
of that Zachery little fringe science is
a great word that people ought to start
using more often there's a great deal of
things in physics that have a scientific
rigor backing them but not not the
mainstream opinion okay um Dan the man I
know you've said you listen to metal did
you ever listen to death I used to love
them so much back in high school the
final album is very influenced by nature
I think I've listened to them before but
I didn't really get into them I don't
like at all metal I mean I'm not into
Slayer
I like thrash metal but I'm I you know
I'm and other had never got into Slayer
then somehow it never just clicked you
know so it's if you know you can like a
whole genre without without getting into
a particular group the stuff I'm into is
you know but earlier in time I went to
death come up I mean they're still
touring right let's see here
okay 483 so they go back quite a ways
yeah here we go pioneering force and
extreme metal sub-genre of death metal
not into death metal
you know just not my my stick so alright
21 Studios says great channel longtime
fan well thanks that's very nice of you
to say and thanks for the contribution
alright fgh did you watch the new Joker
movie is it out already
yeah it is out already now right I've
been so busy lately with seven classes
stoical week starting Monday stoic on X
here all these things that I've been
seeing ads for it but I didn't realize
that it was already out it doesn't
actually look very interesting to me I
have to say and I do like you I can't
Phoenix but yeah I think we're gonna
make the decision not to see it in the
theater and just see it when it comes to
wherever Netflix or Hulu or something
like that
human evolution how would you recommend
to learn ancient Greek again just like
with the Latin question depends on the
student right there is no there is no
recipe for that there's a lot of
different approaches so you want to
figure out what kind of what kind of
student you are and then find resources
that other people like you say are
useful
Quinn any thoughts or tips for SCOTUS
well I mean SCOTUS is tough don't expect
it to be like Thomas I guess alright
Giovanna has a really good question I
keep seeing talk of virtue ethics in
contrast with legalism I don't recognize
the name virtue ethics from my time in
the university or grad school but from
what I've been able to read about it it
seems what we used to call principal ism
those sound like like
words from a textbook sort of treatment
of moral theory legalism is usually
gonna be contrasted against not
necessarily virtue ethics but things
like you know love based approach or
more flexible approaches and the idea
being legalism so another word for
legalism would be a certain kind of damn
taluk right and I was just talking about
this in my business ethics class last
week when we use this broad term ding
and hajeck comes from the word day on in
Greek which means you know should or
obligation day is is used as a sort of
generic verb and dant ology can comment
a couple different you know versions you
could have like Immanuel Kant his his
ethics is a deontological ethics but
it's based on a central principle the
categorical imperative which then can be
impact in three different ways and it's
it's very you know it's very complicated
in certain respect but Khan also thinks
the ordinary person can understand it
but there's some things built into it
that would say that you know like mere
rule following for the sake of rule
following that's not what Kant is about
or if you take Ross you know and Robert
outies
more pluralistic approach with prima
facia duties that's a de ontological
conception you could say that stoicism
and Confucianism as as approaches are
fairly de ontological as well but
there's like some reasoning given for
why are these the rules why is this a
duty right a legalist doesn't really
care about that sort of stuff they're
like the rules are the rules are the
rules are the rules they got to put them
in practice you know so there's that now
virtue ethics that's a broad designator
that includes you know platonic
philosophy and the most Italian
philosophies
stoic philosophy arguably even classical
epicurean philosophy I mean they did
they they they didn't think that the
virtues were good for their own sake but
they did think the virtues were for good
so you know those then you've got you
know Christian virtue ethics and you can
even you know if you're doing
comparative philosophy talk about the
treatment of the virtues in other other
areas right so Confucianism it's kind of
a virtue ethics as well a lot of
indigenous approaches are essentially
virtue ethics and what makes it
virtually is the notion that there's
there's important character traits that
you want to cultivate and they're not
just about like social approval or
anything like that they're genuinely
good for that person to have and they're
also generally good in they're gonna
govern their behavior towards others and
make them fit into society better and
they can't be reduced to algorithms or
rules or anything like that that's
another key thing in virtue ethics the
notion that you can't reduce things to a
set of laws you need to cultivate what
we call the practical wisdom or prudence
and you need to exercise good judgment
so that's that's central to the virtue
ethics thing if if what you called
principled ism means having some ethical
principles and following those that you
know that kind of fits in with virtue
ethics but because you can say ethical
principles serve roles in virtue ethics
but it's not quite the same right
so hopefully that that helps out with
that let's scroll back up and see what
we got
actually we're now getting close to the
time when I'm gonna ask that like just
pick a few things that I can answer
fairly easily or straightforwardly
ah
Zak
good question here what qualifications
makes one a philosopher that's you know
there's no single definition of
philosophy and given the fact that we
have you know you can say philosophies
kind of split over a whole bunch of
different traditions some of which we
assemble under these broad headings like
Continental or analytic or history of
philosophy are comparative or classical
American orto mystic or whatever right
it's not like there's a checklist that
would be accepted across the board and
some of those big picture things like
you ask an analytic philosopher what is
philosophy though oh that's not really a
question I can answer you know perhaps
it's not a well-formed concept or you
know you then they bring out Vidkun
Stein's quip you know it's the disease
of which it should be the cure but ask
ask continental people what philosophy
is - and they often can't can't quite
tell you so there isn't really a good
answer to that to that question there's
no like there's no one criterion I guess
you could say that that we can apply all
right so let me start grabbing some
stuff out of the air and see what we
we've got here
bow here's a good one from alejandro
about Lacan right what would you
recommend to read to get into the cab
and getting interested in his work but I
don't don't know where to start
so this is gonna be a little
counterintuitive don't start with the
Acree the atria are quite difficult
deliberately so lekanoff you're showing
off or sticking it to somebody and
you're not even sure who he's like who's
this preface for right and it's like a
hodgepodge of different papers from
different points start with his seminars
you know those are those are quite
accessible they're still difficult but
they're way more accessible than the 88
and I'm actually moving forward a bit
because there's a
so another book that I think I would
recommend it's very short and I thought
this a number of years ago it's kind of
interesting it's called the triumph of
religion preceded by the discourse to
Catholics you know like the the the
context that wakhan was in there are
many Catholic thinkers and Lacan himself
thought he was an atheist but he thought
that contemporary atheists were kind of
screwing things up you know like he if
he were around today he wouldn't like
the new atheists because he thought that
Christianity although you could say like
literally false was figure it was it was
sort of you know figuratively true and
that we would be impoverished by trying
to take it completely out of the scope
of things so I would check that out Oh
Giovanna has a follow-up we had legalism
and tension ilysm consequentialism and
situationism yeah I mean those are the
sort of things those are those are
categories that are probably coming from
some textbook approach they're not
broadly recognized in moral philosophy
that sounds this like the sort of thing
you get in a seminary I don't know if
that's that's correct but so legally you
know legalism would you could say dant a
la dant ology in a sort of a low-level
intentional ism is saying that okay so
what you've got there if you're talking
about Abelard only the intention really
matters that's a lot more like can't
write situationism
yeah Fletcher wrote situation ethics
Fletcher said that that everything
should be motivated by laws but you know
we can't sort of categorize that and a
lot of people thought that Fletcher was
basically just justifying relativism of
some sort you know so yeah all right
let's see what else I can grab on the
way out I'm gonna have to do my Hegel
thing
before too long and I've got some other
work I'm also I'll mention this going to
my wife's thirty-year class reunion
tonight which should be kind of
interesting I've never gone to any of my
class reunions and I don't know if she
went to any incurrence but we're gonna
be like you know getting to meet some of
the people she went to high school with
so that should be kind of cool all right
let's see what else we got here doo doo
doo oh here's a great question by Tyler
Jaques do you find it harder to focus
when you're reading in this age of
social media and online distractions I
do and I have to make an effort to put
my phone down I'm not sure where my
phone is right now it's around here
somewhere
that was gonna use it as a prop I have
to make a deliberate effort not to alert
us not to you know get on the phone and
like see what's happening on Twitter or
how many emails I've got and stuff like
that
and it's good to make that part of your
sort of reading discipline I don't think
you have to necessarily do things like
you know put your phone away you know so
it can't be looked at or anything like
that but it's it's you know it is a
serious problem right now there's
there's what we call you know illiteracy
when people can't read and then there's
what we can call a literacy that's when
they don't know how to read well and if
what you're used to reading is just you
know texts and blog entries and stuff
like yeah sitting down to read a complex
book written at a time when that sort of
electronic stuff was not the norm and
the only really distracting you know
thing like that would be like newspapers
or television it can be very tough and
and I you know actually so this is how
all em because it's now almost 1:30 here
I'll say that what we what we want to
think about
is not you know whether we're screwing
it up right we're going to screw it up
anything that's a temptation you will
give in to that temptation at one point
or another it's important instead that
you you know you recognize when you fail
you recognize them like you didn't you
didn't pay attention to a passage
because somebody you know distracted you
distract yourself with with technology
but then you get yourself up and you say
alright I'm gonna go back to this and
there will be some days where you can't
actually get back into it but you you
just try it the next day and the more
that you stick with it provided you're
not like getting you know getting down
on yourself about it you will eventually
either acquire that habit that you
didn't have or you'll get it back there
are many people who really need to do
that these days and it like I'm saying
there's more of a distraction because of
that now so we have to make more of a
deliberate effort in order to not be
distracted by that and that's just the
burden that we we labor under so I'm
gonna end there and thanks for all of
the questions it looks like there are
quite a few conversations people are
carrying out in the chat window well
while I was talking about things thanks
everybody for showing up and we'll do
this again of course next month by the
time that that happens I will have a
little bit less on my plate
so have a great afternoon if you're here
in this area or evening or morning
depending on where you are or if it's
the middle of the night thing like
Australia or you know China or India
hope you have a great whatever it
happens to be